[Música]
Bienvenidos a una semana en el mundo el
programa de France 24 donde los
periodistas son los invitados y
analizamos las noticias que han marcado
la actualidad de la semana en este
programa vamos a hablar de cómo va a
afectar al panorama político y social en
Estados Unidos la imputación penal de
Donald Trump por los documentos
clasificados de mar a lago también
hablaremos de porque el Mediterráneo es
la frontera más mortífera del mundo
comentaremos también el renovado interés
de la Unión Europea por América Latina y
finalmente de si china puede conseguir
la solución de los dos estados para
Israel y Palestina pero antes pasemos a
saludar a nuestros invitados de hoy que
nos acompañan desde Buenos Aires y desde
Ciudad de México empezamos a por saludar
a nuestro invitado en Argentina Federico
Vázquez Él es director de la radio
futurock y conductor del programa sobre
política internacional un mundo de
sensaciones Federico Muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en France 24
Le agradezco mucho su participación en
este espacio y le empiezo preguntando
con Qué temas usted determina la semana
en que se ha estado fijando estos
últimos días
bueno
varios de los que nombraste tal vez el
que
me estuvimos reflexionando justamente
preparando el programa Nuestro el
domingo tenía que ver con el que
nombrabas
del este de la tragedia que ocurrió en
el Mediterráneo una más
donde decenas de personas perdieron la
vida no
antes de llegar a las costas griegas y
en ese sentido
bueno es algo que ya lleva muchos años
recuerdo la soleadas migratorias de hace
una década atrás también muy intensas en
su momento en el Mediterráneo
conforme
se comenzaba un momento de inestabilidad
muy importante en algunos países de
África particularmente Libia
después ahí nomás Siria también
y siempre vemos
creo que se aborda esa cuestión en
términos periodísticos referido a Como
esos migrantes
o refugiados más precisamente
son tratados en los países a donde
llegan o intentan llegar no en este caso
se sale países europeos y poco se pone
el pulso
o la preocupación o los interrogantes
sobre Por qué algunos países siguen
siendo lugares que expulsan a sus
propios ciudadanos Me parece que ahí
está la cuestión y las preguntas y hasta
te diría también la responsabilidades no
no Porque esos países en jaltan
responsabilidad sino que a veces se
generan situaciones de desestabilización
política que después que la gente huya
totalmente ahora abordaremos esta
cuestión Pero antes saludemos a nuestro
invitado desde Ciudad de México Andrés
apascoeles periodista y director
editorial de cuestione punto com Andrés
Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en France 24 le traslado la
misma pregunta brevemente con Qué temas
termina esta semana
Hola Rosa primero que nada un gusto
estar con ustedes de nuevo un saludo a
ti y a todo el auditorio y a mis colegas
Muchas gracias por la invitación el tema
en México en este momento es la sucesión
presidencial lo que se ha comido todas
las noticias es que pues Ya empezaron a
renunciar los miembros del gabinete y
demás funcionarios que buscan
ganarse la candidatura de morena que es
el partido gobernante para para ser
candidatos a la presidencia el próximo
año y es una asociación sumamente
adelantada no en realidad deberían estar
empezando a hacer esto en noviembre a lo
mucho y eso ha creado un gran desorden
Pero además muchas dudas sobre la
legalidad del asunto porque aquí tenemos
lo que llamamos las
condenas por campañas adelantadas
entonces ahí todo un debate legal y
político sobre si esto es legítimo o
están en realidad violando algunas leyes
y lo vamos a estar viendo y exactamente
vamos a seguir este tema muy de cerca
pero ahora Les propongo que empecemos
por una cuestión también aquí en el
continente americano empecemos en
Estados Unidos donde recordemos para
contextualizar el martes la justicia
estadounidense imputó al expresidente
Donald Trump de 7 delitos por haberse
llevado recordemos documentos
clasificados de la Administración
estadounidense cuando abandonó la Casa
Blanca documentos militares o de
inteligencia que deberían haber pasado
bajo custodia del archivo nacional y que
sin embargo el FBI encontró en lugares
tan inhóspitos a como el baño de la
residencia privada del ex mandatario en
mara lago en Florida recordemos son 37
cargos los que pesan sobre el
expresidente 31 de ellos relacionados
por la retención intencionada de
información de defensa nacional 3 por
guardar y ocultar documentos en las
investigaciones federales dos por
falsedad y uno por conspiración para
obstruir a la justicia
junto con uno de sus empleados
colaboradores wall-nautas les empiezo
preguntando Andrés empezó por usted por
cercanía geográfica le pregunto En
primer lugar por qué Donald Trump se
llevó estos documentos porque estaría
interesado en llevarse estos documentos
a su residencia privada
bueno hemos visto en varios casos de
distintos expresidentes que se llevan
documentos o altos funcionarios que lo
hacen y podemos suponer Aunque siempre
va a ser una especulación que tiene
mucho que ver con
la aspiración de tener información
relevante Donald Trump como sabemos es
un hombre muy ambicioso con
aspiraciones de poseer lo más posible Y
quizá pensó que tener este tipo de
documentos le iba a servir lo que es
interesante del asunto para Mi gusto es
si estas investigaciones lo ayudan o lo
perjudican porque en realidad tenemos un
debate interesante Sobre el asunto
porque galvanizan a sus bases no a los
estadounidenses les encantan las
conspiraciones entonces pues esta es una
conspiración perfecta el estado
persiguiendo el sistema persiguiendo a
un líder Rebelde
al mismo tiempo también lo ponen una
posición judicial muy frágil Y eso ha
creado una fractura interesante en un
partido republicano que lo podremos
abordar un poco más adelante exactamente
pues Federico le traslado este dilema un
poco en Estados Unidos El del
departamento de justicia de probar que
todo el mundo es igual supuestamente
ante los ojos de la ley y el hecho de
que estas causas Donald Trump las
utilice de hecho para hacer campaña de
Cara a su posible reelección para 2024
recordemos que en una encuesta de este
mismo jueves Donald Trump continúa
liderando de lejos la carrera dentro del
propio partido republicano con un 53% de
los apoyos lo sigue muy de lejos con 30
puntos menos rondesantes el gobernador
de Florida Entonces cómo finalmente se
puede resolver este dilema entre
alimentar los argumentos de Trump o
hacerle pagar ante la justicia su
responsabilidades
Sí está muy bien la idea del dilema
porque no hay una una resolución obvia
creo lo que que esto se engloba algo más
general que no está pasando Solo en
Estados Unidos Aunque en Estados Unidos
es muy marcado pero en nuestra región en
América Latina y en general con
dirigentes políticos por ahí de de otra
vertiente ideológica pero está pasando
lo mismo que es una judicialización
extrema de la política no hay estamos
viendo cada vez más dirigentes políticos
desfilando por tribunales por distintas
causas algunas este más
donde hay algún algún sustento más serio
otros no recordemos el propio Lula hoy
presidente estuvo más de un año preso
efectivo en una celda Sí esa es la
situación general Me parece que más allá
de la cuestión de Trump Y estos
documentos en particular que como bien
anotaba el colega anterior no es una
práctica que tuvieron otros presidentes
en Estados Unidos hay unos grises allí y
demás cuestiones lo que creo que que Es
evidente que estamos ante esa ante un
marco muy complicado donde la justicia
cada vez más funciona para distintos
sectores políticos
como una una última Barrera para la
propia disputa política eso lo vemos en
nuestra región con mucha preocupación
porque de ahí acondicionar después las
este situaciones electorales el derecho
de los ciudadanos y demás Hay un solo
trecho y en concreto en Estados Unidos
yo me animo a arriesgar esto por la
declaraciones de los propios líderes
republicanos de las últimas horas lejos
lejos de despegarse de Trump como bien
decían también la conclusión es obvia en
general lo que hacen es politizar aún
más la situación y
construir una narrativa en la cual
trampas hacer un un perseguido político
a mí me parece que más allá de este caso
en particular lo que habría que desarmar
es el nudo donde la justicia es
utilizada para resolver cuestiones
políticas hace 30 años esto no era así y
Andrés le pregunto pero sin embargo en
el sumario que ha aportado la fiscalía
las pruebas que se han aportado en este
caso consta una grabación según una
exclusiva adelantada por CNN en que el
propio expresidente digamos reconoce
tener documentos clasificados militares
concretamente una plan de ataque a Irán
le pregunto con este tipo de pruebas tan
evidentes Cómo se puede defender
judicialmente el ex mandatario y si
tiene sentido un poco respondiendo a
Federico finalmente embarcar Estados
Unidos en este proceso en un momento de
precampaña electoral
Trump está en un problema legal profundo
realmente le va a ser muy difícil salir
adelante de estos sin cargos ahora pero
recordemos esto los requisitos en
Estados Unidos para ser candidatos son
mínimos básicamente tienes que tener
cierta edad y ser estadounidense él
podría incluso hacer campaña desde la
cárcel si fuese el caso porque ha pasado
antes en la historia de Estados Unidos
hubo alguna vez algún comunista que hizo
campaña desde prisión en en Estados
Unidos entonces
podría irse a la cárcel ganar y auto
perdonarse el tema es y lo que me parece
interesante es cómo se ha fragmentado el
partido republicano en este proceso que
se ha creado en básicamente lo que me
parece que son tres grupos principales
no los que son anti Trump como Chris
Christi los que son pero críticos como
pens y y de santis y los que realmente
están totalmente con él como vivik y el
asunto es
todos todos van a necesitar
jalar a la base electoral de Trump
porque sin ella ninguno va a ganar
Entonces cómo compites contra Trump
ganando sus votos Y ese es el desafío
que van a estar enfrentando estos
compañeros y compañeras candidatas pues
para ir cerrando este bloque sobre la
imputación a Donald Trump Federico
terminó con usted y con un
acontecimiento que también sucedió esta
semana Y es que recordemos en la pasado
lunes murió Silvio verlos con y exprimer
ministro de Italia y un personaje al que
se le ha relacionado mucho con Donald
Trump no se le haya ayudado a llamar
como lo hizo Miguel Mora en el medio
contexto el político que inventó el
trampismo de hecho le quiero pedir una
reacción a precisamente a un párrafo de
este de este artículo que dice hoy por
fin ilcaimano descansa en paz pero las
ruinas culturales y políticas que dejó
su dominio sin embargo se han extendido
por el mundo y tardarán todavía un largo
tiempo en ser reconstruidas le pregunto
la presidencia de Trump también
representa una decadencia cultural una
decadencia social en Estados Unidos
bueno por ir demasiado tiempo para para
eso la presencia de Trump fue hace
relativamente poco tiempo creo que sí
lo que decíamos antes la la democracia
en Estados Unidos pero no solo en
Estados Unidos las instituciones
democráticas para ser más precisos estar
en una crisis una crisis de
representación insisto con la idea de la
judicialización y traes a ver luzconi y
déjame decirte que coincido no haberlos
como una especie de antecedente global
de populismo de derecha y demás
cuestiones que podemos señalar pero
sobre todo hay un dato que no dejaría
pasar el origen de verlos con y cuál fue
fue además de ser poseer grandes medios
de comunicación que no es un detalle es
el antecedente donde Italia vivió una
especie de judicial judicialización muy
fuerte la política de que terminó con
muchos con la destrucción del sistema
político básicamente los grandes
partidos italianos del siglo XX
subsumidos en corrupción y demás Pero
sobre todo con una agenda judicial que
del maniquí se acuerdan ustedes que
decía vamos a barrer con la con la con
los malos políticos y vendrá una nueva
generación que alumbre no una República
Quién vino Trump Perdón para los coña en
el caso de Italia entonces Fijate De qué
manera el punto que se haya yo antes que
parecía medio por ahí abstracto de que
resolver las cuestiones de la política a
través de la justicia es un problema
importante el antecedente berlusconi es
es tenido de serpiente eh Porque
berlusconi surge y después gobernó sobre
todo en los años 90 casi sin oposición
fue el líder italiano
hegemónico durante mucho tiempo Exacto
pero a base de la destrucción de las
instituciones políticas italianas que
habían durado 60 años de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial entonces tendría mucho
cuidado estudiaría ese caso cuando fue
la prisión de Lula en Brasil se habló
mucho de presente el mal y política esto
es un juez diciendo voy a limpiar no a a
los políticos que este te roban para
decirlo
simplemente Y eso desencadena después
una dinámica política que son muy
difíciles de de frenar y que en general
los beneficiarios terminan siendo
liderazgos que que están por fuera de
los de los barcos de los partidos
políticos de las instituciones me parece
encontrarme empezamos también a ver eso
en en Estados Unidos y me parece que
está bien linkear no lo que lo que traes
vos en relación a al fallecimiento del
líder italiano pues Federico Gracias por
esta conclusión a este bloque sin duda
es un tema que no se termina Aquí y
ahora pero Les propongo pasar a otra
cuestión que sin duda también ha marcado
la actualidad de la semana y nos
quedamos en Europa en concreto frente a
las costas de Grecia donde recordemos
este miércoles naufragó una embarcación
en la que han muerto cenas de personas
por el momento hay la confirmación de 78
fallecidos y de más de 100 personas
rescatadas con vida sin embargo
persisten centenares de desaparecidos
todavía a esta hora en el mar
Mediterráneo esto según la organización
internacional para las migraciones que
señala que en esa embarcación que
náufrago Podrían haber hasta 700
personas a bordo por lo tanto estaríamos
hablando de uno de los episodios más
mortíferos de los últimos tiempos en el
Mediterráneo que de por sí es la
frontera más mortífera del mundo
recordemos otra vez según la
organización internacional para las
migraciones 27.000 personas han muerto
desde 2014 en este mar que recordemos
une Europa Asia y África y para abordar
esta cuestión tenemos la suerte de
contar aquí en el estudio con una de
nuestras jefas de edición y también la
directora y presentadora del programa
migrantes de esta casa de Franz 24 y
Julian riaño Muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros
le pregunto entonces para que nos ayude
a contextualizar porque el Mediterráneo
es la frontera más mortífera de Europa
Bueno pues de Europa no del mundo Perdón
del mundo Sí bueno para entenderlo
tenemos que ver también las cifras no
que tú acabas de decir casi 27.000
migrantes han muerto en esta ruta
migratoria desde el 2014 cuando la
organización internacional para las
migraciones empezó a hacer este conteo y
Y por qué pasa esto y porque es una de
las rutas más peligrosas pues veamos
Quiénes son las personas que están
migrando por esta ruta son personas que
están huyendo de persecuciones de
conflictos de guerras en países de
África de Asia de medio oriente también
y que ya En algunos momentos han tratado
de viajar por las vías legales y entrar
a esas fronteras europeas por las vías
legales pero no han recibido Pues el
visto bueno de Europa Entonces cómo lo
hacen además lo hacen en unos botes que
son botes incluso inflables botes de
goma en los que ni siquiera tienen
garantía ni la seguridad en las que van
a poder llegar hacia destino en buenas
condiciones con seguridad y cómo Pues
solamente teniendo unos chalecos
salvavidas que además es lo único que
les garantiza Pues que van a llegar bien
a su destino Pero además estamos
hablando de una frontera en la que se
judicializa la labor de las
organizaciones de ayuda porque por
ejemplo recordemos lo que pasa con
Italia
Italia permite Puerto a las
organizaciones de ayuda pero las
condiciones entonces las organizaciones
de ayuda puede salir a navegar a
rescatar a los migrantes que están a la
deriva pero no les garantiza pero
solamente tienen que ir al puerto que
les están dando y no pueden regresar o
no pueden recoger a otras personas que
encuentren por el camino entonces allí
También estamos viendo un poco la
judicialización que están teniendo estas
organizaciones de ayuda que no permiten
tampoco el rescate en esta frontera en
la más mortífera para los migrantes en
el mundo y Juliette quisiera recoger
algo que usted menciona y es
precisamente el hecho de que las
personas que utilizan vías irregulares
para migrar es porque digamos carecen de
alternativas legales para viajar no
precisamente Y en este contexto es
cuando se criminaliza sobre todo a las
redes llamadas de traficantes de
personas no las personas que finalmente
aprovechan la falta de vías legales para
facilitar rutas a clandestinas no y de
hecho ya en el caso de Grecia hay 9
acusados de tráfico de personas en
relación con esta embarcación Federico
le pregunto a quién sirve finalmente
este discurso que siempre digamos se
pronuncian las autoridades europeas en
que criminalizan no ponen la lupa sobre
las llamadas redes de traficantes de
personas como si fueran la causa del
problema y no una consecuencia de las
políticas migratorias europeas
sí totalmente Bueno ahí es creo que en
general hay todo un discurso o el
acercamiento a la cuestión de los
migrantes que en el caso de lo que
estamos contando en el Mediterráneo Es
particularmente dolorosa bueno la
noticia que estamos reseñando es
terrible
insisto en que esto viene de hace años
usted recuerdan hubo otras pero hace
unos diez años una ola muy importante
también con con muchos fallecidos
durante semanas en las costas europeas
Me parece que el abordaje siempre se
queda en insisto en Cómo se reciben o no
a los migrantes lo que vos hablabas de
quienes se benefician de este negocio
Porque además es un negocio por supuesto
que tiene intermediarios nosotros en
América Latina también conocemos de esto
del todo lo que tiene que ver con la con
la migración
por Centroamérica México para llegar a
Estados Unidos y todo eso existe y es
real ahora nunca se pone el foco
responsabilidad que me parece que es más
obvia de Por qué la gente se va de esos
países para la gente huye No es que está
no es una no es ni siquiera es una
emigración para acceder a una vida mejor
sino que están huyendo estaciones
desesperantes Porque viven en países que
están arruinados no en el caso de Libia
que se entiende donde salió este barco
creo que está confirmada Ya esa
información por lo menos estaba como
hipótesis muy fuerte que había salido de
Libia bueno Libia sabemos un país que
hace diez años después fue bombardeada
se hace sino al presidente ese momento
Libia había un caos los que no veo es de
parte de por ejemplo Europa
como un proyecto de estabilización de
Libia lo mismo podríamos decir de en el
caso sirio no Dónde están los proyectos
para proyectos económicos de ayuda a los
gobiernos de esos lugares para que sus
ciudadanos No emigren la verdad que si
solamente el problema de empezar a hacer
cuando esas personas viajan
que que los estados europeos en este
caso los reciban o o tomen medidas más o
menos Este humanitarias me parece que es
quedarse muy la superficie cuando el
problema real es que millones de
personas están yendo de sus países sin
querer irse se van porque son países
destruidos esas destrucciones tienen
responsabilidades políticas no insisto
el día fue un verdeada fue desquiciada
no tiene prácticamente gobierno bueno es
una estación desmadrada ahora no vemos
ahí una agenda política de los gobiernos
muy poderosos sobre todo europeos porque
están cerca de ese país me refiero y
tuvieron jugaron la crisis Libia una
intención de ver cómo desarrollan ayudan
a que se desarrolle el IVA para que la
gente deje de irse si no es un mal que
va a dar una más o menos
humanitariamente se va a seguir este
arrastrando durante años Julieta
Aprovechando que Federico hacía este
paralelismo con el continente americano
también con la situación de la migración
aquí le pregunto Cuál es digamos la
similitud a las diferencias a gestionar
la migración en la Unión Europea y en
Estados Unidos con México no dos
fronteras que separan el norte del sur
global Bueno aquí vemos una un gran
parecido y es el tema de la
externalización de las fronteras
entonces vemos que ambos ambas regiones
tanto Estados Unidos como Europa usan a
terceros países para o para mantenerlos
allí como hace la Unión Europea con
Turquía por ejemplo que a cambio de
miles de millones de euros tienen un
acuerdo y Turquía sirve como una especie
de muro de contención para evitar el
paso de los migrantes hacia los
migrantes y refugiados hacia Europa eso
por un lado por otro lado vemos el caso
de Estados Unidos que también usa
terceros países seguros que son países
en Centroamérica básicamente a los que
Estados Unidos retorna o regresa a los a
los migrantes y refugiados que necesitan
protección hacia esos países para que
esperen allí en unos países que no son
ni siquiera del que salieron ni al que
quieren ir en país que no sabemos si es
seguro para ellos tampoco que esperen
unas respuestas a sus solicitudes de
Refugio Entonces al final Como que
los países del Norte global no están
atendiendo las causas reales de la
migración de por qué estas personas
tienen que salir de sus hogares por
causas de conflictos o guerras o otros
temas o violaciones a los derechos
humanos y ese es el punto que no
atienden realmente las causas sino que
están cuidando sus fronteras y
bloqueando sus fronteras sin atender las
causas de la migración y Andrés le
preguntó desde México usted tiene esta
esta cuestión de la gestión política de
la migración por parte de Estados Unidos
ahí digamos en su en su propia casa como
como lo ve que similitudes que
diferencias ve entre la Unión Europea y
Asia y áfrica o Estados Unidos respecto
a América Latina
para nosotros ha sido Muy conmovedor el
caso de este naufragio porque es algo
que vemos todo el tiempo tenemos
comunidades enteras viviendo en la
frontera de personas que Estados Unidos
ha rechazado y ha dejado en nuestro país
y nos hemos visto obligados a recibirlos
y ha habido enormes problemas porque ha
habido también muy mal administración en
Cómo se cuida y cómo se atiende a estas
poblaciones migrantes Nosotros hemos
hecho varios reportajes sobre las
horribles condiciones en las que viven
pero lo que me parece especialmente
grave de este caso del naufragio es que
era totalmente prevenible
organizaciones sociales como el
Armstrong y otras habían advertido de
que había un barco con horas de
anticipación que estaba teniendo
problemas o que se había volteado y las
autoridades europeas no reaccionaron en
particular las italianas y las griegas
entonces
todos estos muertos no hacían falta y
esto es lo que vemos Nosotros en
nuestras propias fronteras con Estados
Unidos todo el tiempo gente que muere No
porque no haya habido condiciones para
salvarlo sino porque nadie se tomó la
molestia de hacerlo pues gracias también
por concluir este bloque Juliette
Muchísimas gracias por habernos ayudado
a contextualizar las políticas
migratorias en la Unión Europea y aquí
en el continente americano a ti gracias
por la invitación Rosa y a ustedes les
ofrezco la posibilidad de seguir con
nosotros con otra cuestión también que
hace referencia a la América Latina y es
el renovado interés de la Unión Europea
por esta región un interés que ilustró
la presidenta de la comisión europea
Úrsula bonder Legend con una gira por
Brasil Chile Argentina y México y en la
agenda de la mandataria estaba entre
otras cuestiones la ratificación la
renovación de distintos acuer dos
comerciales con la Unión Europea y el
mercosur o también Unión Europea México
Unión Europea chile le empiezo
preguntando a usted Andrés Cómo ven
desde desde México este interés este
acercamiento de la Unión Europea en
estos momentos
mi percepción es que esto tiene mucho
que ver con la necesidad de Europa de
acercarse a América Latina para
desplazar un poco a China china ha
trabajado muchísimo durante mucho tiempo
para y acercarse y Europa está empezando
a sentirse desplazada
en México ha sido muy bienvenido pero
pues nuestro socio comercial es Estados
Unidos y va a ser nuestro socio
comercial eterno y más importante
siempre entonces pues con Europa podemos
trabajar algunas cosas pero realmente
nunca va a ser este especialmente
prioritario ha sido más interesante lo
que ha pasado con Brasil y Argentina que
han tenido profundas diferencias en los
acuerdos que hacen Y de lo que veo es
que
Europa está teniendo dificultades para
atender el tema de las asimetrías
económicas que hay Porque hacen una
serie de exigencias que Pues quizá le
podrían hacer a otros países europeos
pero pues para países como Brasil o
Argentina decirles que tienen que
contener determinados controles o
determinadas reglas de producción y
sobre todo temas los temas
ecoambientales que son tan importantes
pero son tan difíciles y económicamente
complejos para América Latina pues han
creado roces importantes pero a mí me
parece que es muy importante sobre todo
con las nuevas tecnologías y el ascenso
del litio y etcétera creo que yo creo
que puede ser profundamente beneficioso
para ambos continentes no más espero que
se logre hacer desde una perspectiva
equitativa y justa precisamente le
pregunto Federico desde Argentina
Cómo ven el acercamiento de la Unión
Europea como algo que pueda ser
beneficioso para la región y en
particular para su país y en qué medida
ven que esto sea una especie de
contraataque a la influencia que gana de
China no solo en Argentina sino en toda
América Latina
empezaría diciendo que como el colega lo
refería respecto a México con Estados
Unidos en términos de relaciones
comerciales tanto para Brasil como para
Argentina los últimos años claramente el
socio comercial más importante fue China
y es algo que sigue sigue ese rumbo la a
partir de la de la fuerza del comercio
eh No no por ninguna otra cuestión
básicamente es quien más compra los
productos que que más exportan en en
estos dos países
lo de la Unión Europea es algo de larga
Data hace rato que el mercosur y la
Unión Europea vienen buscando explorando
un posible acuerdo y lo
lo que habría que reseñar es que el
punto muerto el que se llega siempre el
mismo que básicamente que lo que tiene
para ofrecer
nuestra región en términos de
de competitividad más importante es
producción este agrícola
Y eso choca con ciertas barreras de
subsidios de Europa a veces se esgrime
cuestiones vinculadas a los sectores
agrícolas franceses o alemanes como se
decía Recién ahora también en los
últimos años cobró relevancia lo que
vendría a ser las regulaciones
medioambientales
como sea eso al menos desde desde
nuestros países se ve como distintas
trabas para el ingreso de lo que sería
la producción
de este lado que más podría beneficiar
en una en un en un acuerdo y el segundo
punto muerto es la misma contracara de
eso que es un acuerdo Unión Europea
mercosur tendría primero que
desenganchar esta idea de que la
producción primaria de nuestros países
pueda llegar libremente al mercado
europeo cosa que hoy no ocurre y al
mismo tiempo la contracara es que parte
implicaría un meter en muchos problemas
la producción industrial de Brasil y de
Argentina que no está los niveles
europeos pero tiene sobre todo una
producción industrial diversificada en
términos de automóviles este
equipamiento metalmecánico vinculado a
la industria la cuestión de las patentes
y la verdad que hasta ahora en estos
diez años mínimo un poco más que se
llevan intento de negociación nunca se
superaron esas dos trabas no sé si no no
vi elementos que que hagan cambiar esos
ejes por ahora Pues Federico Andrés Nos
quedamos sin mucho tiempo pero no quiero
cerrar este programa sin plantearles
algo que mencionó Lula de hecho a la
propia bunder Legend en su visita a
Brasil en el marco de conversaciones
sobre la guerra en Ucrania y Lula dijo
necesitamos más diplomacia y menos
intervenciones armadas en Ucrania en
Palestina o en yemen no y precisamente
ahí quería acabar a nuestra conversación
y es precisamente que parece que china
se perfila como un actor que podría
estar digamos dispuesto o disponible
para mediar en la solución de los dos
estados entre Israel y Palestina
recordemos que esta semana el presidente
de la autoridad Palestina visitó Beijing
por invitación del presidente de quien
le propuso un plan de tres puntos y
quizás el más relevante es el primero
que dice la solución fundamental radica
en el establecimiento de un estado
independiente de Palestina que disfrute
de plena soberanía sobre la base de las
fronteras de 1967 y con Jerusalén este
como capital esto según citó el medio
global Times les pregunto muy
rápidamente creen que china se erige
como potencia diplomática después de
restablecer relaciones entre Arabia
Saudita e Irán es momento de que pueda
lograr avances en esta cuestión Federico
Bueno está muy bien lo que traes rosa de
de ese china tuvo un capítulo
recientemente que por primera vez
involucró en en una agenda en medio
oriente que a priori no no era de un
lugar obvio para China o que ocupaban
otras potencias en el mundo en este caso
que vos nombrás de Palestina veo lo
mismo por supuesto que veo difícil
cuando es difícil aprender no veo que
china tenga las herramientas para lograr
resolver un conflicto de décadas como es
el palestino israelí pero me parece que
es otro síntoma muy notorio de que china
está
convirtiéndose o animandose a jugar en
ese tablero internacional con una
particularidad muy interesante o muy
importante que es que a diferencia de
los actores que vimos sean occidentales
o también podríamos incluir a Rusia en
el caso chino tienen para escribir ellos
hasta ahora como una bandera importante
para encarar negociaciones en lugares
conflictivos es que china no tiene una
tradición de países o de ser tener una
injerencia directa no Entonces en ese
sentido cuenta a priori con una con un
background de su propia historia
positivo para convertirse en un actor
que lleve Paz a distintos escenarios o
negociaciones veremos después si esto lo
logra traducir en políticas concretas No
pues Federico Andrés Lamentablemente se
nos acaba el tiempo para abordar esta
cuestión tan amplia pero muchísimas
gracias a los dos por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en France 24 en una semana
en el mundo y a ustedes recuerden pueden
ampliar y toda esta y más información en
cuatro punto com
[Música]